monsieur bousille modeste ingénieur des
arts et métiers a mis au point un moteur
savamment dissimulés dans le cadre de
cette bicyclette de course
le tube vertical renferme le moteur dont
monsieur barry ancien champion cycliste
régional et minutieux techniciens nous
livre le secret dans ses deux tubes là
nous avons mis les batteries relayée en
trail par un circuit électrique et en
bout de notre moteur un réducteur ce qui
permet naturellement de tourner les
manivelles à environ 100 tours minute
alors que me te re tourner à 6000
tours/minute
vous voyez également ici un pédalier qui
n'est pas comme les autres il est enrôlé
mans et nous avons dû faire ce système
là justement pour permettre la roue
arrière lorsqu'on s'arrête de pédaler
que le pédalier tourne encore pour
permettre de recharger nos batteries ce
soit dans les dessins soit dans le faux
plat ce qui nous donne une autonomie
constant des batteries la puissance de
ses batteries et le 48 10 watts sont
nécessaires pour recharger les
accumulateurs
l'autonomie d'utilisation et de trois
quarts d'heure dire qu'il suffit
d'appuyer sur un bouton pour économiser
20 % de l'effort physique habituellement
engagé regarde pour la mise en route
naturellement nous avons une craquante
que nous mettons sous la selle comme
ceux ci nous avons ici un bouton de
contacter si vous voulez la clé du
démarrage et vous vous voyez je sépare
sur home trainer on atteint une vitesse
de 45 kilomètres à l'heure
le poids supplémentaire apportée par
cette installation à un vélo standard et
de deux kilos et demi
mais l'utilisation de matériaux plus
légers permettra de diminuer cette
charge la puissance maximum que peut
développer un cyclotouriste bien
entraînés peut atteindre 200 watts 50
tours minute
on constate en comparant les puissances
que ce prototype n'est pas une mobylette
mais requiert de la part de
l'utilisateur une propre disponibilité
d'énergie
que peuvent donc apporter ce prototype
comme nous l'avons vu rien aux cyclistes
spécialité
par contre il fournit à ceux qui ne
disposent que d'une aptitude physique
modérée une aide non négligeable
appelons cette machine si vous voulez le
vélo santé c'est pourquoi on pense que
ce vélo là qu'on viendrait surtout aux
fans qui le suivent leurs maris aux
handicapés ou cardiaques qui doivent
faire du vélo parce qu'ils ont des
articulations qui ne fonctionne même le
docteur leur dit de faire du vélo mais
faut pas forcer et vous savez lorsqu'on
est sur un vélo on a toujours tendance à
forcer un peu plus que ce qu'on peut on
se disait c'est pour demain j'oserais
j'oserais
demain quand on lira sur les chemins
si calais